almost all American journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
news voice is a one-of-a-kind mobile app
that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the news stories
we consume every day and it's completely
free to use go to news voice dot-com
slash Pakman to download it you all know
that I don't think Donald Trump is a
good president I don't think he's an
honest person I don't think he's
competent I believe he's way in over his
head
he's the worst president I've personally
lived through but I also hope you know
that when Trump or anyone does the right
thing I'm not afraid to say it and in
some small ways Donald Trump did some
good things yesterday while also doing
many many bad things during his
coronavirus press conference and later
on Twitter Trump gave what for him again
for him was his most presidential
statement and briefing on coronavirus
and maybe on anything since the start of
his presidency because Trump came out
and he didn't immediately brag
uncontrollably about how great his
response has been he was initially sober
and quite frankly scared looking and
saying we need to take some serious
precautions and outlining a list of
those behavior changes that need to
happen he actually looked like when I
say scared he looked like he understood
the gravity of the situation and he
admitted coronavirus is not under
control new guidelines recommended by
Trump yesterday home school all kids
don't go to bars don't go to restaurants
no gatherings of more than 10 people
okay no idea whether state governors
will put those policies into action but
we have to start getting through to the
trumpets who are acting like nothing is
going on spreading the disease going to
beaches going to concerts and bragging
about it and that's why this matters
Trump went on to say a whole bunch of
crazy stuff and lies and tweets and I'll
tell you about it but even Trump saying
this matters because this is just math
okay his red state followers have not
been taking this seriously and they are
Banting us from limiting transmission
they've been going to beaches and
concerts and parties and spreading the
disease here is Trump obviously lying
about never having previously said the
virus was under control but at least he
is saying no the virus is not under
control and apologies about the the
tinny audio on this clip we are doing a
very good job within the confines of
what we're dealing with we're doing a
very good job there's been a there's
been a tremendous amount of the the way
they're working together they're working
hand-in-hand I think they're doing
really a great job and from that
standpoint that's what I was referring
to yes control for any place in the
world
so still some deception saying I never
said it was under control that's not
true that's a lie he said it was under
control many many times but he's at
least admitting it is not under control
Trump says the new guidelines might be
necessary might be necessary until July
or August that is mind blowing lis
inconceivable to tens of millions of
Americans but here is Trump laying out
what he sees as the worst case scenario
you have any kind of estimate that if
Americans really were to band together
do with the White House and suggesting
how quickly you could turn this my
favorite question ask it all the time
how many times acity I think I asked
them that question every day and I speak
to Deborah I speak to a lot of them get
the opinion so it seems to me that if we
do a really good job will not only hold
the death down to a level that is much
lower than the other way had we not done
a good job but people are talking about
july-august something like that
so it could be right in that period of
time where it I say wash it washes
through other people don't like that
term but word washes through this the
new normal until five and so we'll see
what happens but they think August could
be July to be longer than that but I've
asked that question many many times yet
now where he did go off the rails was
raiding his response to the virus as a
ten out of ten and on a scale of one to
ten how would you rate your response to
this crisis I'd read it a tenth I think
we've done a great job yeah that that's
crazy
and so that's the the regular old Trump
we know coming out he also kept
repeating who could have imagined this a
month ago nobody imagined this could
happen a month ago
that's not presidential and that's not
honest we've been covering it for months
and we weren't even particularly early
to the game we've all been warning for
months that this is exactly the
situation that could develop and it has
and then also later in the day Donald
Trump losing all presidential political
capital that he gained with the
statement by tweeting about the
so-called Chinese virus saying the
United States will be powerfully
supporting those industries like
Airlines and others that are
particularly affected by the Chinese
virus we will be stronger than ever
before Chinese virus of course
completely xenophobic and discriminatory
and counterproductive in every way
particularly when now China actually is
not the epicenter nor the place with the
most active cases and they have it under
control completely meaningless statement
and then again this morning Cuomo wants
all states to be treated the same but
all states aren't the same some are
being hit hard by the Chinese virus some
are being hit practically not at all New
York is a very big hot spot wet West
Virginia has thus far zero cases Andrew
keep politics out of it of course it is
very political to rebrand it the Chinese
virus this is the same racist xenophobic
blame China blame Chinese people stuff
and Trump clearly not able to remain a
normal person or remotely presidential
for more than a few minutes at the time
yesterday confirm that but
I will take the small win where I can
get it from saying not under control
don't go to school don't go to bars
don't congregate in groups of more than
10 don't go to restaurants and it and
this could last until July or August
it's something that will hopefully
influence his followers Massachusetts is
basically shut down in terms of the
restaurant industry in terms of
entertainment in terms of all of that
stuff gyms are shut down individual
restaurants at least as far as we know
aren't going to be bailed out like the
airlines and the cruise ship industry
and oil companies or anybody else and
even if this goes on until only June the
recovery time for some industries is
potentially going to be years long many
businesses are not going to return from
this and that's horrible but we have to
do what we have to do and that's why
we're taking it so seriously here